you guys who me hello and I'm going to
turn all right how is that that is that
a good volume for you guys it is okay
great and can you guys talk a little bit
so I can hear you guru muffin he looks
very soft for me you guys maybe talk
just talk a little bit louder yes you
can computer great sound like a quality
minutes you can't rush a nice time
against one another out of the way oh I
know that
alright we're just waiting for to our
our brilliant website to you know have
the video page on it and we'll get
started and you guys can you know of all
us the questions that feel free to you
no respond directly to each other as
well that should be you don't have to
wait because that's what fun you know
throw punches whatever do i am dead
longer not even coming okay we're
getting started I'm Lizzie wait I'm a
reporter with science magazine and today
we are having a live video chat from
triple-a asst meeting in Boston about
the future of physics with our guest
Janet Conrad is an experimental
physicist at MIT and Chris Quig who is a
theoretical physicists at Fermilab um so
do I just want to introduce yourself
real quickly and say you know in a
couple sentences what you work on so I
neutrino physicist so I study the
smallest the tiniest of the particles
that are matter particles in the
standard model and the wonderful thing
about this is that even though it is
such a tiny particle it actually is
telling us really big things about the
universe and so it makes a really great
area to study climate any radical
physicists I've worked on things ranging
from properties of heavy quarks and
particles that contain them for
extraterrestrial neutrinos my obsession
and the main preoccupation
luckily to mature tricky physics is
large enough water exposes great um so
for all the other viewers who are
joining us via our website you can
please leave your questions and comments
in the comment section below we won't be
able to get to all of your questions
today I doubt but I will you know we
will be addressing as many as we can so
last summer the the world's eyes were
kind of on the particle physics
community as you discovered the Higgs
boson and today we're going to be
talking about what we're gonna do next
um so what so you know we heard a lot
about this discovery a lot about how you
know it took 40 years 50 years to find
the gig what do what else do we need to
know about the Higgs other than the fact
that it is there like what can we what
new properties of it are we learning
about now no it's a big beginning with
the announcement of the lockport and our
colleague sensitive the elise of
experiments episode Steve nice I've been
working without sitting close to this
problem since time trying to elaborate
the properties of this Couture occult
the eating of running just come to an
end so the LSP about turned off for two
years will be three years during which
there are improvements to the king
frequencies effectively puts the final
analysis of the past what we can say is
that the object that has been clouded
CERN the evidence is developing just as
it would it cannot freakin the Standard
Model Higgs boson be a sort of default
option that we've talked about for a
very long time however the ink evidence
is ambiguous and if you develop further
so we need you to come the fact that
it's really beautiful it's instigating
it really does has lost couples to the
marianas the quantum well that's the one
so the best one of the immediate
consequences is especially since
probably won't be completed this year
for bday today so one of the things that
I would say is that the standard model
is really a model we use the word
standard model instead of standard
theory and that's because we are able to
come up with a set of particles that we
can describe in terms of their
characteristics you can make predictions
for example this week's amounts of the
space was actually a global by the time
you're actually started really looking
forward to HC ah but we don't actually
understand where these uh where these
different characteristics of it is he
needs to de-stress and model of drama so
the more clues we get the better off you
are and in fact with a lot of little
particles will discover them as well we
learn new things about distinguish model
that we couldn't literally attack and so
so I think this is a very standard model
like pigs we have a lot to learn from it
like gathering up more than the hand
feel that we have right now think that's
a very good point that if you think
about 16 samples the ba uncensored 7 you
could say that wants to tell on once we
found it was indeed there but it had a
very long lifetime extensively water
which is giving us looking to do all
sorts of its almost any fun to see
anything virtual I can't agree more
competitive groups which one of these
things there were six occasions to
television back on the way we were able
to learn many new things about what
snakes is this piece for related
question yet another aspect of this
model type of generalities acceptable
risks embodies the laws of nature corn
from Atlantic City Hogan which we test
is to the quad really specific
yeah one of the ways that it returns in
complete this nature women results from
their processes that a pitcher of the
standard normal sugar to better that's a
place we certainly expect if attack and
yet as closely if we work different
system of any players turning out it was
handed not allowing such as I thought
sometimes this is successful if there's
a dynamical principle great so before we
sort of get into um what we're going to
look for next you talk just define up
for our viewers what the standard model
is like what we have been talking about
when we talk about the standard model
and what is the importance and why are
you excited to go beyond it is a Senate
rule ok so we discovered particles which
we believe are fundamental particles
they don't have any kind of constituents
in them and the universe is built on
with these chronicles uh it's kind of
embarrassing because you would have to
have such a model or such a real view
have just a few particles and we seem to
have quite a lot of them and the stairs
of your soil is the set of rules that
tell us how these different particles
behave how they interact with each other
and Navy to explain me interactions
these particles with three of the known
fundamental forces so we've been able to
include electromagnetism the weak
interaction so when we select your wheat
he actually knows two together and then
the strong interaction which is just one
of July dynamics but just is ditching
and it's very embarrassing plus the one
force that everybody out there knows
really well the force of gravity that's
the one we haven't been able to fit in
at all and so that's a big
you're kind of talk about holes in it
yeah uh but we have a set of rules and
it turns out that our particles play by
these rules and Emma melanin we find
that there is a rule which is violated
sometimes it can be violated in a really
big way like for example it turns out
that neutrinos have no mirror example so
you know the nutria looks in the mirror
it doesn't seem I don't like everything
else which looks in the mirror and sees
you know if it's a right-handed person
or right-handed part oh it would see
it's left-handed partner neutrinos don't
have that and it's uniformly violated
such a huge violation sometimes we see
these very tiny little violations like
one of the examples that Chris just gave
was that they called CP violation which
have to do with the wave particles and
antiparticles the hint prepared to each
other and so there are definitely
violations but what we do for these is
we just build that into our list we say
okay most of the time of particles do
this and sometimes they do is so pretty
and you can see you have to be not
satisfactory right we want to be able to
save why they're doing this a whole your
little world this whole little zoo of
particles and and we can't explain wider
than they already are each time we reach
a level of understanding we're going to
go beyond it and ask what lies beyond it
what explains why people where they are
one of the plenty circumstances in the
universe is that the basic particles
which provisionally attempt to be
structured listen to the visible because
of the current limits of our resolution
that's what we see we continue to test
that and all the experiments that we do
because it's not demonstrated them it
really will be will be fundamental
forever nothing else in the past has
been so that's an experimental question
but a working hypothesis well they come
in two varieties so it's going to have
particles and circle left-handed one can
have it versions which are
you
okay we're back on it okay i'll be back
on the page you get the [ __ ] is this
battery really depressed yeah can you
see to put every pocket sorry they
technical difficulties